[Music]
well sharon's here with me now sean i
want to start with this tweet because it
was a tweet that really ignited the
firestorm you just said this as this
marcal debacle went down in the uk you
tweeted this
piece morgan i'm with you i stand by you
people forget that you're paid for your
opinion and that you're just speaking
your truth
what's incredible about that is you
don't actually agree with my opinion i
mean you might well have done you didn't
say
i agree with what he's saying
you just said
he's entitled to an opinion and for that
you end up losing your job yeah because
my my whole point was is that you are a
journalist and a celebrity so therefore
you're paid to give your opinion the
same as i was paid to give my opinion
that's why we're there and
and freedom of speech
when it was all going down on the talk
in cbs
did you imagine in your wildest
nightmare that within days you would
have been fired from the show you've
been on for 10 years
i was actually in my 11th year and the
situation
i never thought
in my wildest dreams that my career
after 50 years would have ended that way
i mean what did did i want my legacy to
be i was fired because i was accused of
being a racist what was so disingenuous
was their initial attack from cheryl
underwood your co-presenter who i know
i've been on the talk many times with
you and with cheryl always very friendly
but that day the mood changed and it
looked like she was deliberately coming
for you
for in her eyes endorsing a racist me
and when you said well what's he said
that's racist she couldn't tell you and
eventually she explained my refusal to
believe meghan markle
basically made me a racist oh yes that
was the whole that was the whole setup
that you were a racist because you
had an opinion on somebody that was of
mixed race
i've never known you have a racist bone
in your body i would like to think
you've never felt that in me never we
are not racist people no we never judge
people because of their skin color i've
certainly never written anything about
meghan markle because of her mixed race
you and i could give
you know that that's not the way we run
our lives
when you got fired
you get turfed out by the cancel culture
mob twitter is a blaze they're joyful
they're gleeful they've got rid of you
they've they've got you out of that job
they've had you fired
for
having an opinion what was going through
your mind when when the first few days
after that it was um
listen i don't scare easily you know
that
but
some of the
comments that were coming through on my
social media were so horrific about
cutting my throat my husband's even the
dogs they wanted to kill my dogs and
then they started on aussie on his site
and then my kids and i just thought this
this is just insanity i had the same
thing i went back to cbs and i said you
not only
can i not earn a living
but now i have to have 24 hours security
because of you and they go like
so what
so your lives were being put under
threat by these menacing people on
social media and you don't know who's
real and who's not
also your career just basically
ended i mean no one would touch you you
were toxic
you were driven out in a race storm
therefore you were untouchable it
it was
i mean literally
untouchable it was from
you know every day stuff comes in when
you do this that and you know charity
stuff and everything the phone never
rang that was it you are untouchable so
when people say cancel culture doesn't
exist
you live through it and you live through
it because of me
and i thought what happened to me was
bad now what happened to you to me was
utterly shameful but council culture is
real isn't it you become
this person that no one will want to
employ because suddenly you're that
person oh absolutely you are untouchable
you are an untouchable and what makes me
so mad is i'm in a blessed situation
that no matter what ever happens to my
career my husband will always take care
of me but what happens to a person
that you know say i didn't have a
husband and i had kids to bring up right
what happens to people like that that
are cancelled or fired because they've
said use the wrong term or something's
taken out of context and they're fired
to the average person what happens to
that person have you ever spoken again
to cheryl underwood who was your
co-presenter on i um sent her
three texts of apologies and she never
got back and then she went on to um
national tv and said that i hadn't
apologized so what i did was i
actually on my social media printed the
text
and then she said well that's not an
apology because uh it wasn't i wanted a
in a phone call and she never called me
and let me just hold one moment what are
you apologizing for i thought you had
nothing to apologize for
what i'm also interested in is what
happened to you later because your life
i mean it didn't completely fall apart
because you had your family but it was
incredibly tough for you it was tough
for me and it did affect me um mentally
i i it honestly did because after
everything that i'd felt all my dreams i
had achieved everything that i'd wanted
to do i had achieved and did i want my
legacy for my family to be oh well your
nana was on television
but everybody said she was racist so she
never went on television again and that
kind of
me up what did that do to you it kept me
up i couldn't i must have cried for
three months
never stop crying and my friend
um
sarah gilbert who used to you know know
from the tournament right she she was
the one that came up with the idea for
the show and was on it and she said you
need help you've got to go somewhere and
she recommended somewhere and then i was
doing therapy and ketamine treatment
did you get suicidal at any stage
not suicidal because i didn't want to
give
cbs the satisfaction
i'm so glad that we're able to sit here
now talking about this and we're going
to come to why you're here and what
you're doing next in a moment
you're going to be
doing what you do best talking about
news and current affairs and stuff in
the in the papers and so on i've got to
ask you about the trump interview he's
clearly hinting in my interview that he
may run again he's still popular in
america very popular with joe biden
being such a disaster at the moment you
could see a situation where trump gets
re-elected would that be a good thing do
you think for america
no i don't think it would be a good
thing and the thing that frightens me is
um
there is nobody
nobody that you could think of that
would make a great president
so the competition is non-existent we're
both monarchists we love the world
family how damaging is this drip drip
drip behavior of megan and harry running
a kind of rival
royal family without any of the need for
the duty that goes with that but with
all the money that comes their way from
fleecing the royal title it's just
tragic that you can
go and try and ruin a monarchy and
you know what we all grew up with loving
adoring respecting and then every time
you open your mouth it's about your
family and the other thing i think that
nobody's ever said is their children
their beautiful children have no family
they don't speak to megan's family
they don't speak to the royal family
these children are going to grow their
grandfather
there's no grandfather there's no aunts
there's no family so just think of your
children
when they when you're talking about
cousins and aunts i don't even think
about anything about themselves and
and the bottom line
i'm about to do something special come
on
i'm about to formally uncancel you
because you're back now at talk tv
thanks the same network with me well i
was delighted to help be part of getting
you back here how important is it to you
to be back on television doing what you
do best on a show called the talk it's
very important to me it's something that
i love
and i just again you know didn't want it
to end my career in such an ugly way and
how is aussie my great man is just one
of my favorite people in the world been
through the health wars a bit how's he
doing he's doing okay he is he sends you
his love
and he's really looking forward he's got
one more operation left to to do and
then he he's dying to come back home
well send him my very best and i'm now
going to have the great honor sean
osborne of officially uncancelling you
to the world and restoring you to your
rightful place as the queen of the talk
let it roll
oh
we need to confess
you